>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> John Haskell: Good
afternoon, everybody.
I'm John Haskell, the
Director of the Kluge Center,
and on behalf of our staff,
welcome to the Trans-Atlantic
Call: People to People.
This has been a week-long
work-a-thon,
is what we're calling it,
sponsored by the John.
W. Kluge Center and the
American Folklife Division.
We have brought together
former AHRC, the Arts
and Humanities Research Council
Kluge scholars to apply their skills
to the transcription, annotation,
contextualization, digitization,
and preservation, the words, most
of them have "ation" in them,
of Trans-Atlantic Call and other
related broadcast materials
that are being brought
together online
by the American Folklife Center.
On this, the final
day of this program,
our esteemed scholars here
will present related topics
that will highlight the
national/international relevance
of the library's folklife
collections.
I should note that sometimes
people note that the side --
the acoustics aren't as good.
And if that's a problem today, then
it's much better in the center.
I'm going to turn it over to the
Head of the Folklife Division here
at the library, Todd Harvey.
[ Applause ]
>> Todd Harvey: Thanks, John,
and I think I should say,
welcome back to the library.
We've missed you.
I am not the Head of
the Folklife Center.
I am a curator at the
American Folklife Center.
I'd like to thank the Head of the
Folklife Center, Betsy Peterson,
for helping us to make this happen.
And especially John Fenn, the
Head of Research and Programs
at the Folklife Center, who
really did a lot to get us going,
as did Travis Hensley
at the Kluge Center.
And especially, Mary Lou Reker,
without whom we would
not be here today.
You have all of our gratitude.
I'd also like to thank our
sponsors, the Library of Congress,
your national library since 1802.
The John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress,
the Library Center for Research and
Scholarship, now taking applications
for the Henry A. Kissinger
Chair in Foreign Policy
and International Relations.
Our sponsor, John Regan Music
Service, a trusted and proven name
in sound reinforcement
throughout the D.C. area.
And the American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress,
join us for real folk
cultural explorations
on a film next Friday and Saturday.
See our website for
more information.
The American Folklife
Center, preserving
and presenting American
folklife, because it's the law.
Well, we have a great show today
featuring a truly trans-Atlantic
group of scholars.
Let's give a big Kluge
Center welcome to Kate Neale
from London Town, Lawrence
Davies of Edinburgh, Scotland,
Delaina Sepko of Glasgow,
the Birmingham of the North,
the man from Cork, Alan
Noonan, and from Chapel Hill,
North Carolina, Sarah Tomlinson.
Did you get mine up?
Our special guest today, of
course, is America's most notorious
and famous folklorist, from
the great state of Texas,
the man who recorded the
world, one Alan Lomax.
Tell us Alan, where
you been so long?
The man who recorded the world-- .
If were in 1939, we'd
be dead, but-- .
[ Inaudible audio playing ]
Well, these five scholars
with me on the podium today,
have had way too much fun this week.
It's been an exhausting week,
and we've spent the week
with a single goal in mind.
That is to provide greater
access to the radio programs,
created by Alan Lomas over a
20-year period, from 1939 to 1959,
with a coda [assumed
spelling] in 1968.
These 300 programs,
showcased the patchwork
of expressive culture
found around the globe
and most specifically,
in the United States.
And I'll trust the
audience today here
to make their own investigations
about Alan Lomax, using the tools
that the American Folklife
Center has placed online,
tools that include more than
300,000 pages of manuscripts,
sound recordings, and photographs.
Each member of the panel, will
contextualize a singular aspect
of Lomax's broadcast output.
And then we'll summarize as a
group our ideas about audience --
the audiences that might benefit
from using these materials
and the tools that we can
employ to reach those audiences.
Our hope is that you will
become engaged as we are,
and as we have been in
the Lomax radio programs,
realizing that this badia
[phonetic] is a small part
of the American Folklife Center's
10,000-plus hours of broadcast.
Hispanic radio, Polish
radio, Yiddish radio,
and that the library's total
broadcasts are easily 10-fold that.
This is a great radio town,
with the library's holdings,
those of other institutions
around town, broadcast outlets
such as The Voice of America,
some commercial stations,
and the crown jewel located a
mile up North Capitol Street,
National Public Radio,
concentric circles, expanding
and engaging our aural senses.
So, let's get started with our
esteemed visiting scholars,
and I will invite Sarah Tomlinson
up to talk about 1939 radio.
>> Sarah Tomlinson: From
October 1939 to April 1940,
Alan Lomax began his first
radio series of many,
when he hosted 25 Folk Music
of America radio broadcasts,
for the CBS American
School of the Air.
These broadcasts listened
to during a school day,
by students in upper grades and
high school, included a wide array
of folk music from sea shanties
to children's songs of play.
Lomax and his collaborators, also
prioritized musical diversity
as they featured works by women
composers like Ruth Crawford Seeger,
African American performers like
Huddie "Lead Belly" Ledbetter,
and broadcast themes such as
poor farmer songs and hobo songs.
As folk music scholar Rachel
Donaldson has argued, the Folk Music
of America broadcasts, show Lomax's
early concern for multi-culturalism.
And throughout the week,
my work-a-thon colleagues
and I have also discussed how
this manifested in Lomax's idea
of cultural equity, a phrase
that he coins later in life.
Lomax's early engagement with
many different styles of music
and identities of people, also
extended to his audiences.
Looking to the Folklife
Center's rich body of material
on the Folk Music of America
broadcasts, we can see
and hear how Lomax engaged
with radio listeners
in multi-faceted ways, such as
through fan mail, classroom manuals,
singalongs, and song collecting.
We can begin tracing Lomax's
engagement with radio listeners
by looking to one of
the many fan letters
in the Alan Lomax CBS
Radio Series Collection.
In 1940, Bill Damon [phonetic],
a member of Mrs. Seegle's [phonetic]
class at the Stratford Ave. School
in Garden City, New York,
wrote to Alan Lomax.
"We have been listening to
your radio programs ever
since the first of the year.
We have enjoyed them very much, but
we have a few criticisms to make."
And to two of these
criticisms first.
"The Negro Quartet
on Tuesday the 13th,
the Negroes clapped their hands
so loud that it was very hard
to understand the words."
And second, "It would
be a lot better
if the programs were not changed."
And then he wrote under,
"What We Enjoyed,"
"These programs give
us a wider vocabulary
of different types and
some of the songs."
The grammar there in
school child [inaudible].
So, this one letter written by
young Bill, came in with a stack
of other letters, all by
students in Mrs. Seegle's class.
And so, she had each student write
to Lomax with criticisms and praises
about broadcasts that aired in
January and February of 1940.
Bill references the broadcast that
the class listened to the same day
that they wrote their letters.
The broadcast was Negro
Folksongs, featuring spirituals,
and aired on February 13th, 1940.
His complaint that the programs had
changed, refers to a schedule change
from the originally planned
program for February 13th,
which would have been British
Ballads in America, a Part II.
Indeed, several of his peers
made similar complaints,
not only about the schedule change,
but also about the
quartets vocal clarity.
The quartet was the
famous Golden Gate Quarter
of African American singers
from Charlotte, North Carolina.
And the students' common
grievances hinted
that there had been a class
discussion about the Folk Music
of America broadcast,
showing another manifestation
of listener engagement, and through
these letters, we can imagine what
that class discussion
must have been like.
While Mrs. Seegle did not
send a letter herself,
her students' words revealed
that she may have had some
racialized notions that musicality
of the African American musical
styles and musicians are difficult
to understand, in addition to her
preference for schedule regularity.
To Mrs. Seegle's credit, the
February 13th broadcast did depart
from an important tool for listener
engagement: The American School
of the Air teacher
and student manuals.
Schoolrooms used these guides
to prepare for and follow along
with the radio broadcast.
On Folk Music of America, Lomax
specifically designed them
to facilitate singalongs.
To prepare for the Negro Spirituals
program originally scheduled
for February 6th, the
manual instructed students
to learn the chorus of
the folk song, "Samson."
And when the program did
air on February 13thm,
Lomax invited students to
sing along as they listened.
And so, in the spirit
of audience engagement,
I invite us all to do the same.
So, first what we'll do is, I'll
sing and we're actually only going
to learn half the chorus,
the first half.
So, we'll do as --
I'll call in response,
and then I'll play the broadcast
and you can sing along with that.
And so, if Lawrence could
give me an [singing].
[ Singing ]
And now, we'll -- oh, one cue is
that you will hear the
quartet sing the chorus.
That's so that you can remember it.
And on the second time,
Lomax will say --
he'll say, "And everyone
in on the choruses,"
and that's the time
that you'll sing.
So, wait until you
hear him say that.
And I'll cue you too.
Okay, you can play the audio.
[ Inaudible audio ]
Excellent.
Thank you for -- I think we
should clap a little bit.
[ Applause ]
Yes, so, by singing along,
Lomax was doing something
that he did throughout his career,
which was breaking down the barrier
between professional
musician and amateur,
saying that we're all musicians.
We should all participate.
And in fact, the singalongs are
one of many devices that he used
to convince children and
general audiences listening in,
on the Folk Music of
America broadcast,
that they too were
contributors to American music
and its cultural history.
At the end of every program,
announcer Niles Welch reminded
listeners, an audio here-- .
>> Will continue to collect
the folk songs and ballads
in your own community, and send them
to Alan Lomax in care of the station
to which you are listening.
>> Sarah Tomlinson: So,
students and their teachers sent
in the folk songs, and indeed,
some of the most exciting materials
in the Folklife Center
are folk songs sent
in by Folk Music of
America listeners.
Similarly, to Mrs. Seegle's class,
they also provide a record
of classroom engagement.
When Mr. Herr's [phonetic] class
from Bethel Township schools
in Pennsylvania, sent in Playground
Songs, there's four of them here,
Lomax replied, "The most pleasing
thing about the American School
of the Air broadcast,
is to receive new songs
and rhymes, that listeners send in.
Your game songs will be added
to the collection in the Archive
of American Folksong in the Library
of Congress, and will be kept there
for study and for future
generations."
And here we are at a future
generation, singing along,
listening along, and continuing
to engage with these materials.
So, let's keep it going.
Learning how Lomax engaged radio
listeners in multi-faceted ways,
through fan mail, [inaudible]
manuals, singalongs,
and song collecting, sort of
an early crowdsourcing, right,
certainly engaged my colleagues and
I throughout this work-a-thon week.
And I hope that this engagement
also extended to our audience today.
And I look forward to
thinking enthusiastically
about how we can continue to
engage new and diverse audiences,
with the Lomax radio materials.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Oh, this is Kate Neale.
>> Elizabeth Kate Neale:
Good afternoon.
The collection and
dissemination of traditional music,
has often had a political dimension.
Folk music has frequently been
coopted into nationalistic projects
in the context of conflict,
often propagating
or constructing an
idealized national identity,
which in many cases was based
on the perception that a soul
of a nation is reflected
in its rote culture.
This was particularly
important in the context
of Alan Lomax's radio work
during the Second World War,
during which time, he
was involved in a number
of groundbreaking radio programs,
both in the U.S. and the U.K.
And due to his institutional
and professional connections,
Lomax was in a unique position at
this important historical juncture.
However, Lomax recognized that
folk song was not only as the voice
of the people, but as
the voice of the peoples.
Rather than promoting a monolithic
vision of an American identity
and culture, he was at pains
to emphasize the plurality
and the diversity of people
and culture within the nation.
This was born out in the
two projects that I'd
like to talk about: The Radio
Research Project of 1941 to '42,
and the broadcast series giving
the title inspiration for this work
from Trans-Atlantic
Call: People to People.
So, at the outset of World War II,
Lomax was already an
established ratio broadcaster
and folk music collector, here
at the Library of Congress.
And in 1941, he was transferred
from the library to the U.S. Office
of War Information, which
was a government agency,
created to disseminate
information on both domestic
and overseas fronts, but also to
build morale in the American public.
And from there, he became involved
in the Radio Research Project,
which was funded by the
Rockefeller Foundation,
and developed by the
Library of Congress,
Dr. Archibald MacLeish at the time.
Lomax's writings of this period,
showed that he considered folklore
and its process of communal
generation selection
and development, to be a
democratic process in itself,
but he was also conscious that this
was true of the many varied regional
and immigrant communities
within the U.S.
During the war, the library's
activities had to be contextualized
by their contribution
to the war effort,
and Lomax wrote several
proposals relating to the use
of folklife material, gathered
by the institution, exploring
and articulating the role of the
Archive of American Folk Song,
in the National Defense Program.
He identified the problem
faced by America, thus.
He wrote, "Well in advance of any
armed aggression against a state,
fascist forces have prepared
the way by spreading dissention
and producing cleavages
among its people.
In counteracting such tactics,
especially in an emergency,
there will be a tendency
towards cultural regimentation,
and writing roughshod over
the emotions and sensibilities
of the nationality groups,
and immigrant populations.
An effective defense program
calls for national unity.
But any effort towards
national unity
that disregards cultural diversity,
will defeat its own ends."
With this in mind, the Radio
Research Project responded
to the problem in one of its out
[inaudible], the Regional Series,
as follows, "In short, we show or
hope to show, the real significance
of the big concept words such as
democracy, liberty, and America,
by breaking them down into
their everyday manifestations
in communities or regions
throughout the country.
These programs do not
speak in generalities,
catch phrases, or glorious words.
The stories are simply told
in dramatic and human terms,
sometimes through the eye of an
individual, be he a reverend,
and old sailor, a coal
miner, or even a river."
In total, the Radio
Research Project,
resulted in six broadcasts
and two -- sorry.
Six radio series and two
standalone broadcasts,
included not only the folk music
and ballad hunting that we associate
with Lomax, but also, oral histories
and cultural memory drawn
from across the country.
Lomax's promotion of national
unity through the medium of radio,
therefore not only took account of
but celebrated America's
internal diversity.
And then we see these ideas
applied in an international setting
in his work on Trans-Atlantic
Call: People to People,
which immediately followed
but was not a direct output
of the radio research project.
Lomax was invited to work
on Trans-Atlantic Call
by the Columbia Broadcasting System,
and the program was a collaborative
venture between the CBS and BVC,
which ran between 1943 to '45.
And was explicitly designed to
foster a friendly appreciation
and understanding between listeners
in the United States
and the United Kingdom.
Initially conceived as alternating
half an hour broadcasts coming one
week from the U.S., and the
next week from the U.K.,
Lomax and his team visited
communities across America,
taking field notes,
making recordings,
and interviewing local people
in order to capture the breadths
and depths of American
vernacular life.
Throughout the broadcasts,
emphasized the impact of the war
and the changes in life
that have been brought
to bear on everyday communities.
The broadcasts directly
addressed the British audience,
explaining the industry's
terminologies
and technologies evident
in each location.
One representative
episode featured Mason City
in Iowa, a large farming city.
And Lomax's field notes, show
that he interviewed characters
from a wide range of
ethnic backgrounds,
including Irish farmers, Greek
canteen workers, and I also wanted
to show this rather -- oop, hold on.
Charming photograph, of Lomax
recording a flock of turkeys
that were eventually
broadcast in the program.
And also, actually got into
conversation with Lomax
and his interviewee at the time.
So, Lomax's field notes
became scripts
that were then voiced by actors.
So, the scripts are fairly
expositionary [assumed spelling],
highlighting potential confusions
from Americans or British English.
Explaining it out for example,
what Americans call corn,
the U.K. farmers would
call maize, pigs, the hogs,
explaining the differences between
English farms and America farms.
And, so on.
As part of his attempt to capture
the breadth of America's social
and cultural diversity,
Lomax also ensured
that American urban life was
represented alongside more
rural communities.
And in one particular
broadcast from 1943,
Lobal visits New York's Upper
East Side, and throughout,
the emphasizes again the range
of ethnic backgrounds living
alongside each other in harmony,
with one character exclaiming,
"Italians, Jewish, Irish,
Negroes, all the same here.
My name's Coco, yours is
Cohen, yours is Fennesey.
We're all alike, 100% Americans."
Later in the series the
format moved from actually --
from half an hour from one country
and then half an hour from another,
to actually switch to
broadcast halfway through,
so there would be a
15-minute segment from America
and then a reply immediately
with 15-minutes from the U.K.
And unfortunately, we don't
have the reply from Soho
which would have replied
to the Upper East Side.
But it would be fascinating
to see if
and how the BBC reflected the
diversity of Central London
in a manner similar
to Lomax's conception.
However, we are able to listen
to one of the replying programs
from the BBC, which
focused on the experience
of women in wartime Britain.
The narrator has just
been seen the morning
after a bombing raid,
and we pick it up there.
If we could have the audio?
>> There are a lot of
people standing around,
people who lost their homes, and
well, they were being advised
by the women and the Women's
Voluntary Service, you know the--
>> Yes, yes, I know the WVS.
>> Oh, yes, that's it.
Well, I went in to see if
there was anything I could do
to help, I guess.
And standing in front of one
of the tables was an old lady.
I suppose she was about 60.
>> I'm sorry to be
troubling you like this.
You must have a terrible lot to do.
>> We're here to help, Mrs. Brown.
That's our job.
>> Well, you see, I -- I
lost everything last night.
My house down, my husband,
they took him
to hospital, but it wasn't any use.
>> I'm terribly sorry, Mrs. Brown.
>> I don't hardly know how to begin.
I -- you see, I've
nowhere to go now.
My girl was killed in
the Blitzen [phonetic].
I've no one I can go--
>> We can take care of
that for you, Mrs. Brown.
The rehousing people at the
Emergency Center will fix you up.
>> Oh thank you, miss.
I don't know where it is.
I thought perhaps you might--
>> One of us will take
you around there.
And we'll call the
Assistance Board as well.
If your house is gone, there's
a lot of things you'll need,
money and clothes and
food and things.
>> That's very kind of you, miss.
I don't want to be any trouble.
I'm sure that there must
be lots worse off than me.
>> I don't think anyone could lose
more than you've lost, Mrs. Brown.
>> Elizabeth Kate Neale: So,
these returning broadcasts explored
aspects and impacts of the war
in Britain that were outside
the realms of experience
for your average American citizen,
often in very dramatic
and poignant terms.
So, Trans-Atlantic Call
and Radio Research Project,
both intended to build [inaudible]
communities with particular social
and political goals in mind,
fostering cultural dialogs
at both sub and international
levels.
The Library of Congress's
holdings relating
to the Radio Research Project and
Trans-Atlantic Call itself, are rich
and broad and include
Lomax's original field notes,
correspondence, institutional
policy reports and documentation,
as well as the radio scripts
and audio files themselves.
And as an ethnomusicologist,
I'm fascinated by the use
of musical material in culture, in
these projects, to build communities
and develop particular
narratives around them.
And there are many interesting
strands to be drawn out.
In particular, how Lomax'
description so much gives a voice
to the voiceless perhaps,
but script the voiceless,
because these scripts were carefully
constructed, curated, and of course,
eventually approved for broadcast
by the Office of War Information.
However, the material begs
attention from a wide field
of academic disciplines
since Lomax's radio work offers
fertile ground for the exploration
and intersection of media
and institutional approaches
to folk like, the construction
and delivery of propaganda,
and the inclusions and the
exclusions of marginalized groups,
all of which concern
us in the present day.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Very pleased to introduce my
co-work-a-thon, Lawrence Davies.
[ Applause ]
>> Lawrence Davies: Thank you.
It's great to be back
at the Kluge Center.
>> Tell us a little about yourself.
>> Lawrence Davies: Okay.
I'm just finishing up my PhD
at King's College, London.
And I was a British
Research Council Fellow here
at the Kluge Center last year.
Some of my work then was on
Alan Lomax and his radio career,
but also how Alan Lomax
presented in particular,
African American folksong
and blues and jazz,
both in America and in Britain.
And one of the things that
I was continually amazed
by at the Kluge Center,
was the facility to bring
in books, right to your desk.
It was a fantastic experience.
And one thing I thought was quite
interesting, is I thought, "Oh,
well I bring -- I won't
bring my own books,
because I'll be able
to order them here."
So, I [inaudible] just being
able to create my library
at home, effectively here.
But within about a month,
it was clear that I was actually
creating an entirely new library
effectively, on my shelves here,
looking at books, making connections
between scholarship that
was entirely different
to what I had made at home.
So, I think that's a really good
testament to Trans-Atlantic travel
for the purposes of scholarship.
Yes. And of course, the American
Folk Life Center was invaluable
for my research, in particular, the
work with and assistance given to me
by Todd Harvey and all of the other
curators at the Folk Life Center.
Being able to really get to grips
with this material firsthand,
and in paper form, brings
things home to you in a way
that even accessing them
online doesn't quite give you.
So. The Art of the Negro, is really
a series that Lomax write not long
after his arrival in
Britain in 1951.
And although, much of Lomax's
work in Britain is on British
and European folk music, and The
Art of the Negro examines the link
between African-American folksong,
religious music, jazz, and blues,
and contextualizes these traditions
within African-American experiences
of life in the segregated south.
So, what I want to talk about today
is not only how Lomax put together
these programs about American music,
but -- whilst he was in the U.K.,
but also how these programs were
used to challenge the status quo,
such as it was in the
1950s, about attitudes
to the broader cultural value of
African-American music and culture.
And I should also say at this
point, that some of the language
in the extracts that we'll read and
listen to have [inaudible] marks
of the time at which
it was recorded.
The series was produced for
the BBC's Third Program.
This was the BBC's Arts
and Culture Station,
formed after the Second World War,
to complement the corporations
of the networks.
The Home Service, which was current
affairs, and the Light Program,
which was mainly for music
and variety entertainment.
And the station's approach, the
Third Program's station's approach,
was firmly highbrow
and intellectual.
The first evening of transmission
began with a lecture on how
to listen, and it included
recordings of Bach's
"Goldbergs Variations,"
Monteverdi's "Madrigals," a lecture
on current affairs by the
Prime Minister of South Africa,
and a concert with
English composers,
[inaudible] from the
BBC Symphony Hall.
What the station did on select
occasions, widen its remit
to the subject of folksong,
particularly if the presenter
was a well-regarded authority
on the subject.
And Alan Lomax was
certainly recognized as such,
by the station's controllers.
So, the Art of the Negro is a
short series, compared to some
of Lomax's other radio projects,
running to only three
hour-long episodes.
These are Mr. Jelly Roll,
about the jazz composer
and pianist Jelly Roll Morton and
the birth of jazz in New Orleans,
Trumpets of the Lord, about
African-American religious worship,
and then finally Blues
in the Mississippi Night,
about the origins, themes, and
social meanings of the blues.
The AFC's holdings
on these broadcasts,
are limited to a set
of finished scripts.
However, these are
exceptionally rich documents.
They reveal how Lomax
constructed each episode
from a wide range of audio sources.
Lomax drew from across
his own earlier fieldwork
and musical knowledge, including
recordings made while working
for the Archive of American Folk
Song, more recent interviews
that he had conducted with
folk singers and musicians,
and then commercial
recordings of blues and jazz.
And without wanting to
go into too much detail,
it's possible to use the
holdings of the Lomax collection,
to dig right down into
this process of authorship.
This slip for example, show
Lomax using the BBC's in-house
reproduction services to make copies
of interview materials he'd brought
with him in preparation
for the broadcast.
And then correspondence files
show the BBC and the Library
of Congress already had a
well-established exchange program,
meaning that many of Lomax's
earliest field recordings,
were actually already over at the
BBC and in their record library.
Lomax [inaudible] source approach,
was integral to his belief
that folk song or folk culture was
a bedrock of American popular music.
In Blues in the Mississippi Night,
Lomax begins by casting the blues
as the musical voice
of a modern nation.
"The term 'the blues'
is old," he says.
"Shakespeare used it.
The song form, is like
the Cante jondo
of Spain, the Fado of Portugal.
All three are routed in Africa,
but the blues is the folk song
of the 20th Century, at home with
machinery, and on city streets.
If America had one national
song, it's probably-- ."
[ Music ]
Can we play that from the beginning?
I'll do my radio intro again.
Or Lomax's radio intro.
[ Music ]
National music then, to Lomax's
ears, was music created and consumed
by the people, within
their everyday lives.
This is evident in Lomax's
recollection of his first encounter
with the blue's musician,
McKinley Morganfield,
better known now as Muddy Waters.
And he recorded, while
collecting songs
in the Mississippi delta
during the summer of 1941.
"He was barefooted
in ragged overalls.
His house, in the middle of one
of those endless cornfields.
He played every Saturday for
little dances in his county,
but he had never seen a good
guitar before he picked up mine.
But listen to his song.
A complex, delicately
balanced, syncopated poem,
perhaps the finest blues on record."
[ Music ]
So here, Lomax is again
turning conventional opinion
about musical value on its head.
Even those who were confined to the
bottom rungs of American society,
with few material resources
and little formal education,
could produce music with immense
artistic value and beauty.
For British listeners
of the Third Program,
this would have been
a powerful image.
While they could access commercial
blues recordings with relative ease,
they lacked any real awareness
of the music's folk roots,
or the environment in
which it was created.
And this is the real
emphasis of this social --
emphasis on social context
rather, it's the real centerpiece
of Lomax's broadcasts here, I think.
Lomax draws on a series of
interviews with blues musicians,
Big Bill Broonzy, Memphis
Slim, and Sonny Boy Williamson,
that he had made in
New York in 1947.
But they are presented
here as taking place
in a back-country Mississippi
juke joint.
"The night settled down.
One of those hot, [inaudible]
August nights
in the Mississippi [inaudible].
The blues was rolling
slow, sleepy, and tired.
It was time to ask questions.
I said, 'Listen, Bill.
You sit here and sing
the blues all night,
and never seem to get tired of them.
What are they about anyway?'"
>> Some people say that
the blues is a [inaudible],
but I don't say it like that.
I say it's a man that's got a
companion and she turned him down.
And things like that
happen, you know?
And that's why I gets
the blues from.
When I want to see my baby,
and want to see her bad,
and something happened
and I can't find her,
and that gives me the blues.,
>> Lawrence Davies: So, although
Lomax's setting is fictionalized,
the musicians' testimony was
direct and from the heart.
Speaking under pseudonyms to protect
their identities, Broonzy, Slim,
and Williamson, spoke candidly
about their experiences
of crushing manual labor, harsh
treatment by white bosses,
and how the blues could be used
to voice the trauma
of these experiences.
>> I've known guys, they wanted to
cuss out the boss, and he was afraid
to go up to his face and tell
him what he wanted to tell him.
And I've heard him say sing
those things, sing words,
you know, back to the boss.
Just be behind the wagon, hooking
up the horses or something, and then
or the mules of something.
And then he'd go to
work and go to singing,
and said things to
the horse, you know?
Horse [inaudible] like the
mule, stepped on his foot.
Said, "Get off my foot, God damn
it," or something like that.
You know? And he meant he
was talking to the boss,
"Son of a bitch, [inaudible] get off
my foot," and such things as that.
That's the point.
>> Yes, blues is kind of
a revenge, you know it-- ?
>> Lawrence Davies: So, these
accounts laid bare the evils
of segregation, but also the
optimism and resourcefulness
of spirit that helped
people survive.
Such as this apocryphal
yet sinister tale
of a delta farm owner
named Mr. White.
>> I know a man at my home.
They call him Mr. White.
That was at on the plantation.
Well, he had his own place there.
It was about 50 or 60
miles of his place.
It's a square, you know what I mean?
From one side to another, you know?
And all his fences around
his place was white.
The trees, he painted them white
up as far as you could get.
And all the cattle and the sheeps,
the goats, and the hogs, and cows
and mules, horses, and
everything on his place was white.
And anytime that his cow or his goat
or [inaudible] have a black goat
or a black sheep or a black calf,
a black colt, anything like that,
he give them to the niggers.
He didn't want nothing
on his plantation black.
>> Lawrence Davies: To be
able to hear such lengthy
and personal accounts of life
in the south and in such detail,
was unprecedented, not only in
Britain, but in blues scholarship
as a whole in this period.
These broadcasts were
therefore an early step
in understanding the unique
circumstances that gave rise
to African-American
traditional music, and how Black
and expressive culture inspired
American popular music as a whole.
Moreover, we can trace
from this one broadcast,
how Lomax continually reused and
reformulated the field recordings
and interview materials
that he used in the Art
of the Negro throughout his career.
His interviews with African-American
musicians became the inspiration
for several books, LPs, and
even a documentary film.
Lomax clearly heard great
power in these recordings,
and I think we can hear that same
power when we listen to them today.
In this way, the future engagement
with Lomax's radio materials
that his project aims to inspire,
will hopefully allow
the important messages
of the AFC's collections
to continue to be heard.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
If I could now hand over to my
colleague, Dr. Delaina Sepko.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Delaina Sepko: I'm just
going to switch it up a wee bit.
Stand here if that's alright
so I can see the slides.
Thank you very much for
joining us this afternoon.
It really means a lot
to us to have you hear.
And could we have the
first sound clip, please?
[ Music ]
>> Alan Lomax: Get on board
everybody, and ride with me.
This is Alan Lomax, your ballad man,
inviting you for another
ride on the Folk Song Train.
The train that runs wherever
the people make their music.
[ Music ]
>> Dr. Delaina Sepko: Thank you.
I'm here to just introduce you
a little bit to another one
of his radio broadcasts, called the
"The Ballad Man" or
"Your Ballad Man."
And to a particular episode
called, "Singing Newspaper."
Now, the broadcast took place
on the 17th of July, 1948.
And it was one of 60
episodes that aired
between October 1947
and January 1949.
In terms of construction, there
were two 15-mintues halves,
with a total of 30 minutes,
and the broadcast took place
on Mutual Broadcasting Network,
which could be considered one
of the four major broadcasters
of that time.
They were topical in nature.
So, when they were put together,
they might be about women and men.
In this case, it's
about popular topics
that you might find in a newspaper.
This particular episode, which
I have here the playlist for,
shows that it's generally
composed of recorded music,
some live performances,
and Lomax gives commentary
over the top of most of it.
So, it might be what
you would find familiar
from today's radio broadcasts.
So, in that respect,
it has a very sort
of dee-jay sort of approach to it.
However, this playlist is
entirely made-up of prerecorded,
commercially recorded music.
What we can see from that is
that we've got a combination
of live performance and recorded
music that's happening during each
of these broadcasts, and what
we can see, although I'd hoped
that was a little bit bigger there,
what we have is a request
for reissue, basically.
So, what was happening is the
broadcast would play a song,
people would write in, in the way
that my colleagues been already
telling you about, asking,
"Where can I buy that record?
Where can I get that song?"
Well, a lot of them were really
difficult to get your hands on.
So, here we can see
a demand for reissue.
People are wanting copies.
Copies that are commercially
produced, in this case.
Now, anybody who's familiar
with commercial music,
knows that there a few hoops that
you need to jump through in order
to be able to play them, and
this was the case even back then.
So, here we can see a list
including some of the songs that are
on this particular episode, asking
for those tracks to be cleared.
Meaning, given permission
to play them on the radio.
So, what we're starting to see
in this case, is a little bit
of tension between folk music,
which is generally seen as something
that you share, that
you do as a community,
and that's something that's very
much part of American cultures
in that respect, versus,
commercial recordings,
things that are commodified and
require permission for broadcast.
However, Lomax still incorporates
a lot of the traditional formats
that he's been using in all the
other broadcasts where he's asking
for input, looking for
feedback from people,
and really wanting an exchange.
The sort of recursive
format, a back and forth.
Something that is reflective
of the folk communities
that he works for and with.
And in this respect, you could
sort of see these broadcasts
as [inaudible] a conduit
for folk music
and folk cultures that
they're part of.
So, in this case, we
have a letter, and --
that he's written to
somebody who sent stuff in.
And it's just an expression
of gratitude.
I hope that he can get
it into his broadcast,
but that he's only got eight songs
that he can play per episode,
it might take him a
little while to get to it.
And then the other image is in
fact, a list to honor those requests
that came through,
a list of requests
that have been made from fan mail.
So, they are keeping track of these,
with you know, hopefully the intent
to include them at a later date.
Whether they made it in or
not, I can't say right now.
I think there's probably
another talk in that.
But what we can see from
here is that back and forth.
However, let's go back to the fact
that this is a constructed format,
and here we can see -- although it's
seven years prior to this broadcast,
already Lomax is being selective
about the things that he's playing.
And when it comes to
commercially available folk music,
he is very selective.
In fact, [inaudible] probably worth
reading a little bit of it here.
So, "After listening to 3,000-odd
commercial records of white
and negro songs, and tunes from
the south, I've compiled this list
of 350 representative titles in
order that the interested musician
or student of American society,
may explore this unknown body
of Americana with readiness.
But, I have come away from
this listening experience
with the certainty that
American folk music,
while certain folklore specialists
have been mourning its decline,
have been growing in new
directions to compete
with thick musical
commercial music."
So, here we have a sense
that he wants to share,
but he's careful about
what he shares.
So, while we can see a lot of back
and forth, a very discursive sort
of program going on, he only wants
to share very particular
sorts of things.
So, while he is a conduit,
he an arbiter of sorts.
So, it's worth bearing in mind
that that's what's happening here.
So, we begin to see a tension.
If you're not aware of it
already, on the one hand,
we have conservation and the very
acts -- the field recording trips,
the concerts, the broadcasts,
the books, and the recordings,
all of the things that
Lomax is involved in.
All of the projects and all of
the output that's he creating.
These are an attempt for
him to both find, collect,
and share American folk music with
Americans and the rest of the world.
And in this case, because at
the time, he is sort of in
between Library of Congress work and
his trip to the U.K, he is very much
within the music industry
at the time.
So, he's working within a very
commercial industry in that respect.
And here we can see that he will do
that to achieve some of these aims.
However, we can start to
see issues of dissemination.
How that product, how
that music, gets to people
who might be interested in it.
So, here we can see that he's used
the wide-reaching formats like radio
and commercial recordings
to achieve that.
We can also see that there are
administrative hoops that need
to be jumped through, in
order to gain access to some
of those recordings
and to play them.
So, what we start to see is the
tension within, the intimacy,
and the personal ownership,
something that is therefore there.
Something that someone
can identify with,
rather than something that's
released en masse to everyone else.
Now, I think that it would be easy
to start asking questions
like, "Whose is this?
Was he right?
Was he wrong?
Who's got the right
answer in this case?"
And I think that the
really interesting thing
about having collections
like Alan Lomax's,
is that it's up to you
guys to make that decision.
This isn't for me to tell you.
It's not even for Alan
Lomax to tell you.
These collections, these songs,
belong to everyone, and that's part
of what we're trying to get
across here to you today,
to give you the opportunity
and to give you the
inspiration to look into them.
And find -- we were privileged
enough to go down and look
into the vaults the other day,
and even us, even us old hands
at doing this, still find
joy in just looking at it,
let alone listening to it.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
And finally, I'd like to
introduce my colleague Alan Noonan.
[ Applause ]
>> Alan Noonan: Good
afternoon, everyone.
It's such a sincere privilege
to be here before you
at the tail end of
my Kluge fellowship.
I almost want to just
enjoy the moment, you know,
as we were all kind of
talking about what an absolute
and sincere pleasure it is to
be here and stand in these halls
and do this research,
and look out here and see
so many people interested in
the materials and the things
that we're looking
at and talking about.
I would like to give a quick
thanks, if that would be okay?
And I might slip back
into my [inaudible] accent
at certain times during
this presentation,
so I hope you all understand
me at that stage.
I'd like to thank Steve, Jen, Nancy,
and especially Todd at
the Folklife Center.
Mary Lou Travis, Ted, John, Dan, and
Emily, as well at the Kluge Center.
And I'd also like to thank
my other fellows who were
with me throughout the year and
who are wonderful and sincere help
and I'd just like to
really emphasize the fact
that my experience here has been
such a wonderfully,
productive exploration.
And I want to use the word
"exploration" quite purposefully.
So, allow me to shift gears, which
is probably a bad phrase to use
since Americans use automatic,
but my presentation will
be slightly different.
And in the way of it
being an exploration,
in the way that Alan Lomax explored
certain collections and tried
to collect material, I too came
here, exactly a decade ago,
to explore American
history and Irish history
and the ways that those intersect.
And I had just begun my
graduate career, I was younger
and a little less gray at that
stage, at the University of Montana.
And with the help of
Professor Flores
and Professor Emmons [phonetic], I
began to dig deep into the history
of 19th and 20th Century American
cultural and social history.
It wasn't long before I heard a
song that would become very familiar
to me in my time in Montana.
And it is with this
version of a song,
that I would like to
begin my exploration
into these fascinating
sources with you all today.
So, this is -- yes.
>> Well you hear this old song,
way off out across the flats,
or you can hear bouncing off
the walls of them boxed canyons.
[ Music ]
That song stands for Texas and
Colorado and Wyoming and Montana
and every other state out there,
west of the Mississippi River.
We don't aim to miss none of them on
this old Cannonball Express neither.
Sometimes though, we call
this train Victory Cannonball.
Sometimes we call her
the War Bond Special.
That's because everybody that rides
this train is a war bond daddy.
We had a meeting about
war bonds the other day,
and the main question was-- .
>> Alan Noonan: And then that
section would lead directly
into a piece promoting war bonds.
I mean, they're --
this radio broadcast,
the [inaudible] Armed Forces
Radio Service, Bound for Glory,
was produced by Alan Lomax,
and of course that was the famous
Woody Guthrie playing that song.
He invited American musicians
to come onto the show
and play their favorite songs or
even reimagine their own songs
that they had already known.
And of course, with all
the references to Montana,
that should be a fairly
familiar song at this stage.
And I really just couldn't
interrupt it.
There's an awful lot of layers that
we could dig in further into that,
but I just wanted to start off
with what I kind of started off,
when I was starting to dig
into these collections.
But with this song echoing in
your ears, allow me to pass
onto the next stage which
was, because we had so much --
so little time to dig into the
collections, we decided to divide
up particular broadcasts
into sections.
And so, it was given
to me to look into.
A Ballad Hunter looks at Britain,
which was produced in 1957,
and had these eight episodes.
Now, strangely enough, I started
to look online at these sources.
All of them were on the Library of
Congress, digitized at this point.
The scripts for the episodes,
that is, I should say.
And I was redirected to the
episode, Dublin to Donegal.
This was just me looking up A
Ballad Hunter, Library of Congress.
And as a proud [inaudible], I didn't
think I was going to learn too much
that I did not already
know about Ireland.
Alan Lomax, on the other
hand, expected to find just
about everything travelling Ireland,
but in the two decades
preceding his arrival,
the arch government had
established a folklore commission.
And that was charged with
the preservation of songs
and stories from older generations.
Lomax met Seamus Ennis, and he
is an intimidating authority
on Irish music, who
we will look at next.
But these clips are from Lomax's
diary, travelling around Ireland
where he talks about the many,
many late nights that he had.
[Inaudible] band till 3 a.m.
And then the following
day, "In bed with the flu."
And I'm not sure if it is exactly
the flu that struck him down,
but there were many nights
where his diary notes
that he had ended the night
before, 4 or 5 in the morning,
singing these songs and of course,
when you get these almost
sanitized radio broadcasts,
we're not exactly sure what
exactly are the cultural settings
of these recordings.
Now these diaries again, open up
that sort of deeper understanding
that these were where
songs were sung.
These were where these
traditions kind of developed.
These were where people would
stay up and tell stories,
recite poems, sing songs.
So, that's just one brief layer that
I kind of wanted to just highlight
that the collections might
not dig into too much.
This is Seamus Ennis
and Lomax's impressions
of Ireland I think
are quite charming.
He describes it of course
at first, you know, gray,
winter sky, but a soft gray.
"Further sky on this, and the mists
were a gentle screen from the cold
of the upper heavens, and not
the barbs of snow or ice."
And so, we'll play
the first recording.
[ Singing ]
So, that's Seamus Ennis
reciting what he believed
to be a Dublin song.
And I don't know if anybody else
has made the connection yet,
but Alan Lomax made that connection
with something very quickly.
Can we head back to the other one
and play the second recording?
Sorry, thank you.
>> Alan Lomax: When I heard that
song, I realized I'd come to the end
of a ballad trail that had run
through my own family
history for a long, long time.
Forty years earlier
in a Texas cow town,
my father had recorded
the same song,
but dressed up in cowboy
chaps and a sombrero.
Instead of the old [inaudible]
baby, it as the cowboy
and his little orphaned [inaudible].
[ Music ]
You can imagine how I felt when I
found that the roots of this best
of all cowboy ballads
in a Dublin kitchen.
And when Seamus told me that
he'd heard the same tune sung
in gallic somewhere down
in Cork, my [inaudible].
>> Alan Noonan: Well, I thought I'd
cut it off there because immediately
when I heard that part of the
recording, I was like, "Oh, oh no.
I've never going back
to Cork again now."
And of course, where
else would I end
up when I was doing
research over in America.
But you know, my own native Cork.
And he travelled down to
Macroom, to meet with a woman,
Elizabeth Cronin there on the right.
And Macroom is a few short miles
away from where my people are.
And we'll play that recording now
of Elizabeth Cronin
singing the song in Gallic.
>> Alan Lomax: But we
haven't come to the end
of the trail till we call
a Mrs. Elizabeth Cronin
who at [inaudible] was
wrinkled and rosy and sweet,
like an apple that's lasted out
the winter, and from her basket
of tunes, she straightaway
produced this Dobe [phonetic] song,
put in Gallic this time.
[ Singing ]
The old people say that this
is the oldest tune in Ireland.
And it was the Virgin Mary's croon
when she was rocking the
infant Jesus to sleep.
[ Singing ]
Well, that shows you how a ballad
hunt can bring you back pretty close
to the beginning of things.
And in Cork we found there was
a special lilt in the music.
There in Cork, where the red
earth and bluish rock curl
up through the green, you can look
around you and believe in fairies.
>> Alan Noonan: I like that
charming phrase by Alan Lomax
because there's a lot
to unpack there.
People have this impression of the
fairies being these genial, nice,
lovely things that you might see
on the front of cereal boxes,
but in actual fact, they were quite
malicious and the rumors and curses
and stories and tales
about the fairy folk
or the wee folks are not something
that would be said lightly,
which is funny the way that they've
been so sanitized over history,
and even in the way that Alan
Lomax, back in the 40s and early 50s
when he's compiling these
recordings, is talking about them.
Regardless of that, Elizabeth
Cronin's own story is
in itself sanitized and mythologized
in its own way because the story
that she is saying, that it is the
oldest song and that it was sung
by the Virgin Mary, is a beautiful
story to tell, but unfortunately,
the deeper origins of the song
are quite dark and depressing.
So, this is Padraic O'Keefe
playing the oldest version
of the song that we have.
>> Alan Lomax: With Padraic O'Keefe,
the fiddler, who knew the tune
and said it was composed
during the famine.
"Nobody left in the town, not
even to bury the dead," Pat said.
"Only an old man, he rocking
a hungry baby [inaudible]."
And old Padraic made his
fiddle say, "Mama, Mama."
[ Music ]
>> Alan Noonan: So, for Padraic, his
response to initially being recorded
when he was told my Alan Lomax is,
he told him that it was for the BBC.
Padraic replied, "I don't care
if it's the BBC or the ABC."
He was going to tell a story
and have it be recorded.
And so, he played that song for him.
And a few short miles from Macroom,
where these songs were recorded,
is where I spent my
earliest years in Kilmichael.
And right there, in that
graveyard in the corner,
far left of that photo,
is a famine commemoration
which has recently been
established by the local community.
It was the site of a mass
grave during the famine,
where they would have used coffins
with hinges to put the bodies,
because they had to reuse them.
And on the opposite
view, is my own grave --
or the gravesite of my grandfather.
Not my own gravesite,
but yet another.
But my grandfather is buried
in that same graveyard.
And yet, this act of
remembering, commemorating,
thinking about the past,
and finding something
that you would never expect to
see, in the Library of Congress,
about your own people
and about your own past,
is something that has
really caught me off guard.
And if feels appropriate then,
that here, in these hallowed halls,
and I think I can use the term
"hallowed halls," of the Library
of Congress, that I, like
Alan Lomax, found a connection
that links me back to
the beginning of things,
if not for all things,
then for at least me.
And in this search, the
sense of cultural equity,
really shines through,
that we can read
and understand our shared human
experience, and the shared music,
poetry, and stories within these
collections, and within each of us.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Todd Harvey: Hi,
I'm Todd Harvey again,
and it's good to have the
lobuleers [phonetic] on.
I wonder, John, can
you turn them all
on because -- what
time is it, Andrew?
Andrew?
>> Twenty -- twenty past.
>> Todd Harvey: What?
>> Twenty-past.
>> Todd Harvey: Twenty past.
So, another 15 minutes or so, but I
want to accomplish a couple things
in this 15 minutes, and that is
to let you all interact
with us, if you want.
I think there are some
microphones around.
But also to talk about -- I
mean, you've heard some moving
and thoughtful stories today
about the Lomax material.
How it's impacted each of
these scholars and granted,
we're a bit under the spell at
the moment, because we started
at 9 o'clock on Monday
morning, and I don't think any
of these folks have
really slept since then.
They have just had
their nose into it.
And that's what happens
in a week of this.
We started with nothing
and we've ended with this.
But it's not enough for
us to do the scholarship.
I think what's important is that
we're able to reach more people
than we would just
reach on this podium.
John, can you also put
my PowerPoint back up?
And so, we need to
talk about audience
and we need to talk about products.
And I have a couple slides that I
think will help to move us forward.
Who had that-- ?
>> It's up on the [inaudible].
>> Todd Harvey: Can you
grab it for me, please?
Well, of course the Library
of Congress is interested
in both of these things.
And we've done in a fairly passive
way, because it's just available
on the library's website.
We've put up a lot of
these materials online.
It's an expectation now, I think
that material be accessible online
and we're trying to oblige.
As I said, putting up 300,000
pieces of paper is no small feat.
And if you work a little bit
through this, you'll find many,
many recordings, photographs,
and other things.
But there are other ways that
we reach out to the world,
which is different than
reaching the world.
We reach out to the world using
a number of enterprise products.
And that would be for example,
the library's online catalog
which is a great place to
search and find things.
And then outreach, such as
the library's blog series
and Folk Life Today's --
American Folks Life Center's blog.
If you don't subscribe, you should.
It's a lot of fun.
And through podcasts.
And we have a Facebook page.
We have the library's
Twitter account.
I think there's an
Instagram account.
So, we're trying, but as
I said, that's different
than reaching to audiences.
And we had a really robust
discussion yesterday about reaching
to audiences and if I can summarize,
and then ask for you input.
We have identified kind of
two classes of audience.
And the first would be communities
of origin, or niche communities.
And in terms of communities
of origin,
we can see how the Irish
broadcast can reach back to Cork,
and have that kind of
meaning to a man from Cork.
Probably a deeper meaning
that I could understand
because he's a community of origin.
And a niche interest group
might be the educational kind
of classroom setting that
you were describing earlier.
And those kinds of
things take partnerships.
They take dedication.
They take long patience and thought
and feedback from the communities,
in order to craft something
that's meaningful to them.
Engagement with the mass media
is something else entirely.
And the Folk Life Center does that.
You know, we're going to screen
American Epic, which was a film
that was released on
PBS, I believe recently.
And made a big splash.
It was a feature film and
they used some of our footage
from the Lomax footage in it.
And so, we can engage
with the mass media.
We can talk to filmmakers
about how to use our stuff.
We can even reach out to filmmakers,
but it's in a very different way
than approaching communities
of origin.
It's a press release or a packet
or something like that saying,
"Hey, this is what we have."
Then they take it and
use it in their own way.
Have I at least approached
the discussion that we had?
I think everybody's lob
[phonetic] is up now.
Delaina's?
>> Delaina Sepko: No,
I think you have,
and thanks for the recap, Todd.
And we definitely struggled with
there are almost too many options.
And what was the best way to
do justice to the collections
to get them out as much as possible,
but to do it in a meaningful
and thoughtful sort of way.
We recognized that we have an --
lessons from the past
that we can look towards.
Broadcasts like Trans-Atlantic Call,
that we can look to the formats
that maybe Lomax has
used previously,
and maybe adjust them a little
bit for a modern context.
But we also know that time has
moved on and things have changed.
So, in what sort of way
might we need to adjust those
to make them relevant now?
We know that we have fairly
effective tools in terms
of reaching a large audience.
The Twitter, the Facebook,
all of these kinds of things,
but they are not an
-- they are a vehicle.
They are not a product.
And so, we were very aware of how
we might be able to use those,
in a way that like I said
before, did everything justice.
Did the people that we were
trying to reach a service
and in the same way,
do right by the things
that we were trying
to connect them with.
It's not an easy task.
I'm not sure that we've even
come up with a firm sort of idea,
but we have at least had
time and spent the time
to consider these sorts of things,
and that is precisely why
we're opening up to you guys
at the moment, because we don't
have a final kind of product.
We want everyone else's
collective experience.
We want to maybe hear
your suggestions.
We want to know what you've tried,
what's worked, what hasn't worked,
and then what things would you
be interested in as a member
of a niche community, as
a user of social media,
and all the things
that fall in between?
>> Todd Harvey: Do you want to
talk about maybe a concrete idea
that we discussed yesterday?
>> Sarah Tomlinson: Sure, so I
teach a music appreciation class
at a school in Durham,
North Carolina.
And so, bringing some
of the radio materials
that were originally created for
kids, to the classroom there,
is something that I already have
a community partnership with,
and that we can make happen.
And so, that type of -- and that
sort of fit into our conversation
about communities of origin.
And actually, when we first
found the stack of letters
from Mrs. Seegle's
class, we said, "Oh,
we have to go to the Stratford Ave.
School and show them the letters
that maybe their grandparents wrote.
So, even a more you know, a
school as a community of origin
for school programs, but also the
specific school can sometimes work.
A way you can sort
of incorporate it,
like the Golden Gate Quartet being
from Charlotte, North Carolina.
So, bringing that particular
broadcaster.
They were actually on many
of the school broadcasts,
bringing one of those too.
Some more in Charlotte and
highlighting that local connection.
And I think we also talked
about, that way you sort of see
and know the impacts that you
have in doing outreach activity,
when you work with a specific group,
rather than when you put something
on a mass media platform.
There's more uncertainty about what
its use will be, and the anxiety is
that it will sit there, and nobody
will actually engage with it.
But then of course,
it has the potential
to affect that many more people.
So, I think that tension was
what we were going back and forth
about do you want to do a
[inaudible] impact to a kind
of smaller group or big, but
possibly more risky project, yes.
And we even thought
about packaging --
you can make a podcast about
going to a school, you know.
You can bring them together
in interesting ways.
>> Todd Harvey: Right,
that would be the hybrid.
>> Sarah Tomlinson: Yes.
>> Todd Harvey: If we could
find an institutional partner
to create a series of podcasts
about us going back to the schools
to engage with communities
of origin.
It might be something --
I don't suppose anybody
from NPR is here, are they?
What kind of foster questions
do you all have, if any?
The Folk Life Center you know,
has a lot of experience engaging
with communities, back into --
well, the most prominent
example I can think
of is our federal [inaudible]
project, where we made taped copies
of [inaudible] of Native American
communities, and then disseminated
to those -- you know,
their -- those communities,
their own intellectual property.
Their own cultural heritage.
And those are partnerships
that began with that gesture
and have continued in
a major way ever since.
So, we you know, that kind of
thing is I think very much in line
with the partnerships with
the communities of origin.
And engagement with the mass media
is something entirely different.
What do you think, Nancy?
You have a microphone right there.
>> Actually, I was going
to take the opportunity,
since we have some panelists
from outside the U.S.,
to ask what the impression
is of the Library of Congress
and the American Folk Life Center?
Among both scholars -- I assume
scholars generally know what we
have, but perhaps also musicians
and community historians
and how we might be able
to up our visibility
in the U.K. and in Ireland?
>> Alan Noonan: I might start
digging at that question.
That's a really good question.
I know that [inaudible] was the
Lomax fellow here several years ago,
and she actually turned
me on to the Library
of Congress's collections a little
bit more than I probably would have,
and that was kind of
leading me into to apply
for the Kluge fellowship
here and really start digging
into the 20th Century oral
record, oral histories,
and records of miners and mining
communities, around the U.S.,
whereas you know, I
might have gone --
just stayed in the nice
confines of the 19th Century.
But I think a project like this
gives us a huge opportunity
and a huge avenue to explore
a greater collaborative sort
of outreach, and I
know that that word
"outreach" is awfully dangerous,
but all of us are former fellows
of this institution, and all of us
have had this wonderful opportunity
to be here, even if
just for this week.
I think underutilizing people
like [inaudible] or even myself,
this project here, gives us a
chance to reestablish those links
and reemerge with some other sort of
project and some other reassessment
of these connections that do exist.
I mean, again, like even myself,
and I wouldn't consider myself
you know an [inaudible] Corkman,
I didn't know about
these connections.
That was kind of why I'm kind
of coming to you saying that,
this was a local connection that
I had, that I never understood.
That it added richness and
depth to my own understanding
of who I am and where I come from.
And for a Corkman to admit
that, is a big thing.
So, I think that there is
definitely a path forward.
Where we go on from here, is
really a sort of exciting question.
I think you've touched
on that question,
but we can go further than that.
>> Lawrence Davies: I would add to
that, that yes, there's a temptation
so much at the moment to think
in terms of national boundaries,
both in -- and borders, both in the
U.S. and also in the U.K. You know,
we have the British Library.
We have the British
Broadcasting Corporation
and obviously this is
the nation's library here
at the Library of Congress.
But in reality, the people who've
worked for these and continue
to work for these institutions,
and the collections that they house
and the things that they produce,
always overspill those boundaries.
And so, ways of formalizing --
continuing to formalize those
and to exchange material
and to use material,
could only be a good thing.
I don't want to talk too much
about the Trans-Atlantic Call
because I mean, you've done the work
on it, but one other thing we found
as you said, there's no -- we
can't see the other side of the--
>> Elizabeth Kate Neale: Yes.
>> Lawrence Davies: The -- yes.
You go through it, yes.
>> Elizabeth Kate Neale: So,
what's missing but not missing
because it's not Lomax material
are the BBC replies in some cases
to the Trans-Atlantic Call.
So, I mentioned in the little
talk that I did just then
about we don't know what Soho said
to New York's Upper East Side.
And we don't know the institutional
kind of processes and priorities
that would have informed
that broadcast,
whereas we do know
that from this side.
So, what Alan Lomax
actually achieved you know,
a Trans-Atlantic Project at
the time of a war, you know,
now with our incredibly connected
world, I think we should be able
to build on that and
do something more.
But yes, finding the partners,
building the partnerships,
I think there's a huge amount of
mileage in going back to communities
of origin because the people
who live there now, I mean,
we talked about migration.
We've talked about all sorts of
things, but the people who live
in these locations now, may not
know that there was such interest
from America in their
traditions and their cultures.
Even within America, you know?
Mason City, some of the news
reports that were so excited
about how Mason City would be
presented, not only to the U.S.,
but to the U.K. I think that
it's easy as an ethnomusicologist
and a folklore enthusiast
to be enthusiastic about it
on a personal level, but I think
there's a much broader audience
than just in this room, for that.
>> Alan Noonan: Yes, what's
the phrase we were thinking
of something in partnership?
>> Elizabeth Kate Neale: Sorry?
>> Alan Noonan: There were two
Ps that we were working off of.
The something and partnership.
The differentiation between --
product and partnership, is it?
That we would go to various groups,
be they local, historical societies,
or museums, or local
institutions and things like that,
and we would arrive, and we would
offer them something of interest.
Maybe an exploration
of these sources.
Not necessarily done by us,
but offer them this material
that they might explore themselves
and you know, we would be there.
If they want a collaborative
project,
we would be available for that.
But that -- these alternative
formats might be something
that they themselves could explore.
And so, again, the localism
isn't simply like us going
into the local communities
and saying like,
"We will tell you your history."
It's them further exploring
what's going on at the present,
what happened in the past, and
contextualizing it from there.
>> Sarah Tomlinson: Yes, and
again, what type of product--
>> Alan Noonan: Exactly.
>> Sarah Tomlinson: -they would
use, or that they already use,
so that it can -- so that we're
creating something that is you know,
going to be effective, yes.
>> One of the words I -- thank you.
One of the words I heard pop-up over
and over again, in different forms,
were collaborative outreach,
crowd-sourcing, a reiteration.
And what I hear in that is something
like what Lomax did originally,
which was to go out to the
people and get material coming
in to the collections, you know?
And so, much of what
you're looking at,
I imagine there's still many people
who have heard these broadcasts,
you know, have photos,
have recollections
that could be added to
what's already there.
And putting up something
like chronicling America
which so many newspapers that
scholars use, that researchers use,
wonderful, but the addition
that I keep hearing from you
of bringing in the audience.
I really applaud that.
I think that's wonderful.
>> Delaina Sepko: Well, I think that
was a big part of and how we started
out this week, is that
instead of being --
you know, we all know a thing or
two about music or about Alan Lomax,
but that doesn't make us an
authority on any of it, you know,
in that respect or all of
it, you know, in that way.
And that what we were very keen
to do, was to invite people
into that conversation to bring them
into the process, and in a sense,
leave the produce almost
open-ended at the back,
to allow that space for,
not just for access to old,
but for the ingest of new.
And any sort of form or you know,
we've been calling it product
for a lack of a better word, but
it really does feel like more
of a process, where
things are an added,
things are reimagined,
and then reproduced.
And so, you know, almost the
broadcast, this podcast was a way
to potentially do that, and
that we had an opportunity
to showcase what maybe happened
say, during Trans-Atlantic Call.
You know, when Soho called
and the Upper East Side.
You know, that -- you know,
we know that that half
of the conversation is
missing, but what happened if --
what would happen if
Gloucester, Massachusetts,
calls Gloucester, England?
What would happen today
if that happened?
Or what if Durham, North
Carolina calls Durham, England?
You know, there's a real opportunity
there just in using a city name
as the linchpin and just be able
to work an idea around that.
And create more folk, more
folk culture, more folk music,
the folk whatever comes into it.
And that's where we saw an
opportunity to use things
like social media and other various
kind of digital platforms to allow
that ingest, and then also
to share it back out again.
>> Todd Harvey: I see -- Josh, do
you have a question back there?
And then we'll do one more question,
and then I think we
need to take it out.
We're almost out of time.
>> First of all, thank you for
five excellent presentations,
and six including Todd.
Thank you very much.
I enjoyed it a lot.
So, on the point you guys were just
raising, I think Nathan Salzburg
at Cultural Equity, the Alan
Lomax Archive in Kentucky,
has actually done exactly this.
And he's actually managed to work
with local historical societies
and local schools about
Kentucky history in specific.
That just seems like
a natural synergy
for what you guys are proposing here
since other Alan Lomax areas have
already even had the same concept.
I mean, it's a great
concept, of course.
Yes, absolutely.
So, that's what I wanted
to say about that.
And he'll be at the conference too.
You can talk to him
there [inaudible].
>> Todd Harvey: Right.
Right. And don't forget the Radio
Preservation Task [inaudible]
Conference coming up
in five weeks or so.
Did you have [inaudible]?
And wait for the mic.
And then we're going to
let Alan take us out.
>> My question was just more
specific towards your presentation.
Did you have any audience?
Did you have -- sorry, I'm
like super nervous right now.
Any audience feedback from the U.S.?
Did you look into any of that?
>> Lawrence Davies: Not on those --
on the Arts of the Negro program.
So, those were broadcast
in Britain--
>> Yes.
>> Lawrence Davies: -only.
And--
>> And the audience?
>> Lawrence Davies: There
is some audience feedback.
There's some in the collections but
they're unfortunately not relating
to the episode that I looked at.
There's some to Episode 1, which is
interesting because it's a mixture
of sort of seeing you know, people
here, power and authenticity
and Jelly Roll Morton playing.
And we sort of -- we can
think about that in two ways.
We can either take it at face
value or we can sort of say
that there was -- it fitted --
it may have fitted a stereotype
or something that British
listeners may have imagined
that New Orleans was -- you know,
New Orleans at the turn
of the century was like.
There may be more at
the BBC archives
and the BBC archives are a
little bit more difficult to get
into than the Alan Lomax collection.
So, that's another thing about
this you know, partnerships,
actually matching up these
Trans-Atlantic things.
But of course, as I sort
of gestured to at the end,
this material was used by Lomax
over and over and over again.
And so, we can also look at the
reception to his work more broadly
about things like The Land Where
the Blues Began, the Rainbow Sign
and these various other books,
and things that he wrote.
So, I think it's an area that we
need to look more at basically.
But thanks.
>> Todd Harvey: Excellent question.
And you know, the blues
and the Mississippi Night recordings
I think were considered too hot
to release.
He had intended to release them.
I don't think he released
them for another decade.
>> Lawrence Davies: Yes.
>> Todd Harvey: Because they -- yes.
Because of the imagined reaction.
I want to say thank you to everyone
for spending your Friday
afternoon with us.
And I can't even say thank
you enough to my friends.
And let's have a little
Lomax radio to take us out.
La Partenza.
[ Music ]
>> Alan Lomax: This is the
music of the old port of Genoa,
whose many storied,
close-packed, palazzios,
make a sort of downtown
Manhattan on the Mediterranean.
Winding through those narrow
lanes, you must arrive
at precisely the right hour of the
evening, at a particular wine shop,
that looks like all the other bars
in that foggy and obscure district.
And there you will find, the Genoese
dock workers, drinking flasks
of their white Ligurian
wine, and improvising
in the seven-part, trallalero style.
[ Music ]
Trallalero is a music as richly
textured as a Medieval tapestry,
and is bountifully joyful as
its own green Ligurian hills.
To most Italians however, it seems
unfamiliar and even un-Italian.
You must listen again and hear the
docker who thrums guitar noises
out of his throat, the
tram-conductor's soprano
with his [inaudible]
southern arabesques of melody,
the Tuscan operatic bravura
of the tenor and baritone,
the incredible Sardinian basses.
Listen to this, and realize
that trallalero is the musical
sum of Italian folksong.
[ Music ]
>> Todd Harvey: Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at ww.Loc.gov.